if you had a device designed to freeze
time for everything but you life
wouldn't be anything like what you'd
expect you wouldn't catch up on sleep or
rob a bank while no one can stop you or
cheat on an exam instead you'd be left
blind deaf and unable to move a single
muscle how can time freezing go so wrong
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you could stop time we know
from physics that speed equals distance
divided by time and the time equals
distance divided by speed to make time
equals zero you'd have to travel
indefinitely fast and since we can't
overcome the speed of light stopping
time without breaking the laws of
physics is not gonna be possible but
let's skip the improbabilities and
imagine that time could be stopped
somehow what would happen then
absolutely nothing people would stop
moving water would stop running every
molecule would just stand still you
wouldn't even know that time had stopped
because your neurons wouldn't be moving
either boring so let's add a couple of
modifications to our scenario what if
you were the one to hit the pause button
oh that wouldn't end up well for you not
this time the ability to freeze time
comes with some very unpleasant side
effects first you wouldn't see anything
that's because stopping time would stop
photons the particles of light normally
moving at the speed of well light you
wouldn't hear anything either because
sound waves would stop traveling through
the air to your eardrums you'd be
trapped in between the frozen molecules
surrounding you unable to lift a finger
it would get even worse once you realize
that you can't force oxygen molecules
down into your lungs
blinds death and asphyxiate it hopefully
you could resume time before you passed
out to get around this quick and
senseless end we'll add another
modification this time you'd be
surrounded by a bubble inside of which
time would still be going you'd also be
able to time effect space around you
that would give you the ability to move
and breathe you still won't be able to
hear anything outside of the bubble and
how about seeing well you could move
along and capture light from every
direction but your brain probably
wouldn't be able to decode any of that
information
everything would be washed out not much
fun either so what if instead of
stopping time you just slowed it down
significantly well if you slowed down
light it would shift into the realm of
infrared microwaves and while it could
reach your eyes it would be invisible
same thing goes for sound waves they
drop to a frequency below the range of
human hearing time freezing isn't that
practical after all maybe going back in
time would be a better option but that's
a story for another what-if